welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Jason
Aaron's Thorin currently hammering home
just how good the character is we
thought we'd break down the top five
graphic novels by the writer that you
need to pick up after reading the main
series throughout this video friend of
the show and our an expert Tom cui it's
going to be letting you know which books
you need to check out if you can't get
enough of the main series this is some
of the creators best work and each one
of these deserves your attention now
there may be some spoilers here so if
you don't want any plot elements ruined
at all then I highly recommend that you
turn up now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for quick in
this video now let's get into the
breakdown of the top five Jason Aaron
books to pick up after Thor god of
thunder
hey everyone Tom here and firstly just
to say outright that scalped is my
all-time favorite comic ever it made me
a Jason Aaron fan for life and
ultimately led to me checking out the
rest of this list I mean I like this
series so much I actually bought the
hardcovers after having the trades so
scalped was an ongoing noir crime series
running on vertigo from March 2007 to
August 2012 it ran for 60 issues
entirely it focuses on the Oglala Lakota
inhabitants of the fictional Priory rose
Indian Reservation a world of organized
crime drug addiction rampant poverty
local politics and proud cultural
identity and much like Dickens is London
or David Simon's Baltimore the res feels
like a character unto itself one whose
epic sprawl encapsulates everyone from
chief Lincoln red crow the president of
the Tribal Council and corrupt head of
the criminal empire feeding off the
reservation to Dean oh poor bear a
single dad who struggles to make ends
meet
cleaning up Lincoln's casino and who was
eventually engulfed into the crime world
itself at the center of the story though
and the main character is Dashiell bad
horse someone who left the res 15 years
ago because of its horrors only to
return to find it even worse he's
changed however issue one reveals that -
is under cover back to bring down red
crow as a double agent for the FBI I
would say spoilers but this is heavy
spoilers right and this part of the book
is a particular highlight and - his
constant terror on being caught and his
awareness of all the lines that he's
Rossing continually is is heady and this
is just one of a dozen of electron
threads throughout the pages of scouts
every character you encounter throughout
the book is skillfully drawn in both
senses you want to learn more from each
and Aaron isn't shy with the flashbacks
these don't ultimately detract like
Lindelof however they rather inform the
story intelligently and make us reassess
characters throughout the narrative
knits for example the cigar-chomping
binge-drinking FBI handlers in charge of
dashes post is at first a blowhard
[ __ ] the type aaron has a unique
skill in writing but when you learn more
about his relationship with the murdered
FBI agents that were involved in a
shootout with red crow and Dash's mom
Gina years and years ago this being an
incident that hangs over the entire
story Russian style you know you start
to seen it as a blowhard with conviction
in Aaron is superb at redemption arcs -
and showing lessons learned for
attrition we see this in a microcosm
through Karnow a character encountered
briefly in the early issues and one we
learn quickly is a charlatan able to
impress those in his small town just
across the border from the res that he's
a war hero but this is something that
instantly doesn't cut the mustard with -
amongst other characters we learn his a
fraud but one who eventually redeemed
himself and goes on the hunt for the
night to settle it with red crow in the
end game the weaving of the tone
throughout the book is intoxicating
Aaron and Guerra are as comfortable in a
High Noon brawl or deep underworld
discussions as they are when they're
leaving spiritually into Native American
history I did think early on when I was
reading this initially I've read this
about five or six times entirely now how
is Aaron going to keep up the intensity
you know but for the most part the whole
run is a white-knuckle ride with Aaron
constantly throwing exciting
developments into the mix and foregoing
expectations the book I will say is
unflinching it depicts harrowing drug
use lots of drunken sex and other
peccadilloes a monk's stare and yeah I
love the unvarnished approach nothing is
left on the table or kept under I mean
Aaron feels so confident right in this
world they even takes a small detour I
think it's about the full volume between
a little nook between arcs to focus on
an elderly couple that live far out in
the boonies in in the depths of the rez
and the right here is sparse and lyrical
and the overall story this is a little
short story one shot is is tender and
captivating and just beautiful really I
mean I really could go on and on about
all the characters in scout and maybe
I'll do some more scout videos for the
channel in the future as a whole but
this is just to give you a fragmented
overview of sorts as to why you should
read this spellbinding rich earthy
inspired piece of art and not least of
course as well
after mention as I'm sure you've seen
for help this little segment the art of
our and Guerra himself I mean there have
been other artists on scalped most
notably Jason Latour the Aaron will go
to on Southern bastards which we'll get
to shortly yeah he was a little guest
here you could definitely see his star
going through but Guerra is the star
this scratchy vivid flinty Express and
I'm constantly in awe turning these
pages it's just stunning mature grimy
you know the vision you know is shot
with clarity it's all of the characters
feel so well realized you know very
happy that he would work with Aaron
again on the god damned which again
we'll get to in this list shortly but um
yeah scalped is a masterpiece of Myers
guys if you're not ready get on it
southern bastards in another tale of a
reprehensible individual at the top of a
devoutly corrupt Enterprise masquerading
as a barely legal one comes southern
bastards Aaron's bittersweet address to
the south a comic that simultaneously
celebrates the beauty of that world
whilst also demonstrating which rotten
practices the setting is cruel County a
land of barbecues criminal enterprise
and most importantly football football
football and the man at the center of
every pass and payoff is coach boss
someone who has dragged himself through
so much dirt to get to the top that he
can never be clean and well it's not as
noirish or complex perhaps as scalped at
least not yet the series is still up
there with Aaron's best in the way that
it balances an out-and-out sports drama
with a thrilling action story replete
with characters we're more flesh than
the cooking on offer at the boss
barbecue Jason Latour absolutely knocks
out the park with his deep-fried art
style to his Antebellum colors are rich
and greasy the to Jason's had worked
together on scout before and Aaron
clearly saw a kindred
of his vision despite being grounded in
fixed stereotypes seven bastards is a
constant surprise for instance the man
you're set to believe is the main
character is killed early on it's
actually daughter coming into the fray
later on for revenge Aaron is a master
of setting multiple motivations around a
single event like in scalped where all
the different people Pro rows circulate
around the open a casino and here in
southern bastards the residents of cruel
County are built expertly leading up to
a big game for the Rebs the coach's team
was at the beating heart of the story
that's the third volume but volume 2
however gridiron telling the story of
how this pipsqueak in coach boss rose up
not only to play football to a high
level but manager as well he's
exhilarating with more twists than a
pigskin play that I'm never going to
understand Conan the Barbarian
by Crom Jason Aaron and Conan the
Barbarian is just a match made in heaven
isn't it and I didn't actually know if
in Conan lore there was another name for
heaven so I did a bit of research and
turns out there isn't but he did once
fight a bear from heaven back in 1980
which is what I'd like to see when I die
it's magical journeys outrageous beasts
rippling muscles it's all here and as I
said before you know my Conan knowledge
wasn't much I've seen the movie heard
some feverish Joe Rogan endorsements but
I love this series and from what I can
tell from old school fans this really
feels like a lost manuscript of the days
of yore for those not in the know Conan
is essentially the ultimate fantasy
warrior and Aaron demonstrates this in
the first panel by showing Conan being
born on a battlefield of his mother
cutting the umbilical cord of a knife
that no doubt is soon to be plunged into
an enemies fro so Mel I mean the Conan
presenting here is highly intelligent
heartily brutal and quick with a nasty
retort the stories are quite simple but
really well put together and the artwork
complements everything beautifully often
quite flashy but never difficult to
follow it's funny it's dark you know
there's no real interweaving plot lines
or deep rumination on character
motivations or backstories there are
giant snake beheadings however so whilst
you want the god damned next up is the
god damned a series I was incredibly
excited for when it was announced as it
paired Aaron and Aram Guerra of the
aforementioned scalped together once
more and
although the project is wander you know
undeniably is a fun read narrative Lee I
found it a little and satisfying yeah
we're a long way from the reservation or
the south or actually in biblical times
to be precise which is a mouth-watering
environment but someone has Old
Testament brutal as Jason Aaron can be
the series follows Cain the inventor of
murder who himself cannot be killed
traveling through this hellish post-fall
world as well as the journey of Noah as
well and their inevitable meeting
throughout its bloody
blasphemous is heck the story is filled
to the brim with murderous children
depraved [ __ ] and a bunch of the
goddamned I guess in terms of a story
backbone we explore the world also for a
mother looking for a child and Cain's in
the fall then you know he gains some of
his humanity back in the face of this
there is a real stinger as well as the
ending I won't give away but for the
most part the story is a little typical
um you know this sparse pre civilization
environment means Erin can't really flip
between the Stratus of society as he's
one to do and this hurts me someone it
doesn't mean it's not a glorious journey
for out and Guerra
really shine to some of these enormous
panel that these tableaus that reward if
the story itself doesn't quite after
heft of scalped it's a different kind of
tale it feels a little se me sometimes
and it's snarling combative nature but
still totally worth for read I think it
was like five or six issues has only
been one volume so far but Jason Aaron
did say on Twitter that more is coming
this was two years ago but these things
do take time and you know I'm very first
in line for the Exodus chapter the other
side this was essentially Jason Aaron's
breakthrough and his first me piece of
work fully enough his cousin this is are
gonna have a Vietnam story his cousin
Gustav Hosford wrote the semi
autobiographical novel the short timers
from 1979 on which Full Metal Jacket was
based and he was obviously a huge
influence on Erin in 2006 Erin made a
blind submission to vertigo with this
story his Vietnam war story the other
side and it was nominated for an award
and following this you know he pitched
scalped and and the rest is history the
other side itself tells the story of two
Vietnam War soldiers one Ameri
Billy Everett and one Vietnamese veau
bin died with the cover
beautifully illustrating that these two
men are inextricably linked throughout
the conflict not enemies as such just
the other side of it Billy doesn't want
to go to war he tries to interact VD and
obviously Dai wants to go to war he
volunteers from his village to die for
his country and what follows through
this is a punishing interrogation of the
Vietnam War how it dissolves all resolve
and sanity the story is slightly
different in its pacing and tact from
what I'm used to I mean there are
elements that you'd expect all the four
previously mentioned titles but the war
aspect obviously draws it down different
avenues despite it being an early work
it's mature and solid and the artwork -
Wow the artwork by Cameron Stewart is
top-notch even though we weren't really
there man everybody feels like we are
with this intensity this line work being
so unflinching and severe the other side
is a really grim beautiful kind of book
if you get what I mean it's a human
story in a hellish war scape and despite
not being a big fan of war comics myself
I Ferol II enjoy this book it's painful
and poignant unafraid to ask big
questions and score them with
white-knuckle thrills and that's our
list I just want to give a huge thank
you to Tom for dropping this video on
the channel and if you want to check out
more videos by him then I'll leave a
link to all these other channels in the
description below if you enjoyed this
and want to hear the two of us talk more
about comics that make sure you check
out our podcast watching the Watchmen in
which we analyze the seminal graphic
novel by Alan Moore page by page we are
also currently going over Doomsday Clock
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books and make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition YT
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see you over there after this well so
just one let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on this
list in the comments section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then to make it
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]